in this video we'll be talking about
amyotropic lateral sclerosis or ALS
it's a heiled video for USMLE step one
stay tuned till the end a myotopic
lateral sclerosis or alas is a
neurodegenerative disease which is
characterized by degeneration of upper
and lower motor neurons also there are
skeletal muscular defects
which lead to weakness and paralysis of
the muscles
so this is the lower motor neuron tract
this is the upper motor neuron tract and
in this particular disease both these
neuronal track can be affected
let's talk about the prevalence of the
disease
two or three cases per every 100 000
individual is reported in Europe
in this video we'll be talking about the
clinical presentation of ALS
the pathophysiology of ALS
the diagnosis of ALS and finally the
treatment and management option for this
disease
so let's begin with the clinical
presentation
so in ALS the upper motor neuron tract
can be degenerating or the lower motor
neuron tract can be degenerating and
there are distinct clinical symptoms
which can Define both of these in case
of upper motor neuron degeneration
spasticity and muscle weakness is pretty
much prominent in case of lower motor
neuron degeneration there is a
fasciculation that means twitching and
muscle cramps and rusting is pretty much
common
let's talk about the clinical
manifestations
about 50 percent of the patients develop
cognitive or behavioral impairments in
the advanced stage of this disease
about 33 percent that means one third of
the population has problems like
dysphagia that means difficulty in
swallowing
dysartria that means difficulty in
speaking
let's talk about pathophysiology of the
ALS
o so in the disease ALS like many other
neurodegenerative disease different cell
types are involved that includes
obviously the neuron then the glial cell
types like oligodendrocyte astrocytes
and microglia
there could be exonopathy glial
dysfunction and Hyper excitability of
these neurons let us zoom into one
neuron to understand the pathophysiology
in bit details
so inside the neuron they're one of the
key thing that has been noticed in ALS
is the apparent RNA metabolism there are
several mutations which are associated
with ALS affects this RNA metabolism
pathway
not only RNA metabolism but the DNA
damage repair system is also abrogated
in ALS
the mrnas that are generated in the
nucleus are not properly transported
outside to the cytoplasm there is faulty
nuclear transport
now not only transport even after the
proteins are produced properly somehow
due to many cases due to unknown reason
they aggregate together
and overall the protein degradation or
protein quality control mechanism is
impaired in this disease so proteins are
not degraded
all these aggregated protein
actually affect the mitochondrial
biogenesis it leads to imbalanced energy
homeostasis in these neurons also a
massive amount of oxidative stress is
responsible for the functional
impairment of the neuron because there
are many genes which controls and
regulates the oxidative
defense against the oxidative stress so
when they are mutated there would be
always a problem in terms of
Ross Scavenging
there could be other defects like
vesicular transport defect ION channel
this but this balance all of these are
associated with the pathophysiology of
ALS
now one of the peculiar Factor about ALS
is the localization of the protein TDP
43 it is generally localized in the
nucleus and it's good but somehow in
case of ALS its its localization is
altered it's mislocalized to all over
the cytoplasm and eventually this
actually Aggregates and that is
associated with the degeneration of
these neurons
and this is how it really looks like in
a
immunohistochemistry slide you can see
the tdb 43 enriched in the nucleus and
in case of ALS patient it is outside the
nucleus forming Aggregates like this the
arrows point out
so let's talk about the main genes which
are implicated in amyotopic lateral
sclerosis High throughput a sequencing
has found out many genes which are
associated with ALS just to name a few
sod1 which is a regulator of oxidative
stress so this codes for superoxide
dismutase is highly Associated and very
well studied in context of ALS other
than that there are many genes which are
mutated and they fall broadly under the
category of endosomal trafficking RNA
metabolism and autophagy autophagy is a
process by which the old proteins and
the old organelles are broken down and
recycled so once this kind of recycling
is not happening properly aggregation
happens in the cytoplasm and which is
one of the underlying pathophysiology of
ALS
let's talk about the diagnosis diagnosis
of the ALS can be done using MRI so one
of the key signature that is seen in ALS
is the bright tongue in MRI in MRI scan
other than that there could be
degeneration in the
corticospinal tract that is also very
prominent from MRI reports
besides corticospinal tract the basal
ganglia which coordinates movement and
motor coordination that portion is also
affected a study found out that the
basal ganglia volume is overall reduced
in case of ALS patients
now let's talk about the csf-based
biomarkers so there are soluble
biomarkers like neurofelement like
polypeptide and phosphorylated
neurofilament heavy polypeptide so these
are elevated in patients with ALS but
it's not really reliable because this
kind of interpretation is variable for
different ethnicity patients so it can
be a reliable measure for understanding
ALS
let's talk about the staging of ALS so
there are King's clinical staging of ALS
which stage the ALS into pre-symptomatic
and Stage it as stage 0. then there is
involvement of one clinical region which
is a disease onset time stage one then
involvement of two clinical regions
stage two substantial respiratory and
nutritional failure is stage three and
eventually the stage 4 is death
for example in stage 0 there would be
very less or mild symptoms almost
pre-symptomatic
and in stage two there would be
paralysis and severe symptoms
let's talk about the treatment obviously
ALS doesn't have any cure or any proper
treatment but supportive medications and
supportive therapy can improve the life
quality
so the dyspnea and weak cough can be
treated with proper supportive
treatments like ventilator support
physiotherapy of the chest and mouth
by showing the patient special coughing
techniques Etc
the dysphagia can be treated properly
with let's say speech therapies and
consultation with dietitian teaching the
patient proper swallowing and safe
swallowing technique modified diet and
sometimes in extreme cases insertion of
gastronomy tube
other than that the pain and numbness
associated with skeletal muscular system
can be treated with Physiotherapy
analgesia and sometimes with other kind
of like Therapies
then cognitive dysfunction and dementia
can be treated with specific
antidepressant therapies and overall
other kind of counseling
so I hope this video was useful and
informative if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up you can get more
notes and flashcards in my Facebook and
Instagram page you can support our
Channel using super thanks see you in
next video